نريد أن نحذر مشاهدينا من أن بعض
هذه الصور مزعجة
[موسيقى]
، جاءت المكالمة صباح الجمعة من
رئيس بلدية كراماتورسك ، حدث شيء ما
في محطة القطار ، تعال
فورًا
سمع فييتشيسلاف زاباريزيتس
الانفجار ، فركض هناك
وهناك جثث ممزقة  إلى
أشلاء
57 قتلت
أكثر من 100 جريح
كان هناك الكثير من برك الدم من
الدم
، كان من السهل تتبع عدد الأشخاص الذين
تحركتهم آثار الدم على
الأرض رأيت الكثير من كبار السن معظمهم من
النساء
والأطفال والشباب الذين هم
الأشخاص البسطاء للغاية
الذين لا يملكون سياراتهم الخاصة
، كانت في الأساس الموجة الأخيرة من
الإخلاء قبل الحرب ، كان zaparijits
مهندس إنشاءات في كييف الآن
يقضي أيامه في القيادة حول أوكرانيا
لترتيب النقل الطبي للأشخاص
في البلدات المحاصرة.
والهجمات المحتملة على كييف ، لكني أعتقد أن
الجميع يفهم أن هذه
المدن الصغيرة مثل
المحرقة في خطر  والأكثر من ذلك ، أن
الإجلاء مستمر
ويمكن استهدافهم ، فقد لحقنا
به أثناء سيره من بلدة إلى
أخرى ، وكان من المفترض أن يغادر
القطار محطة كراماتور في الساعة التاسعة من
صباح ذلك اليوم ، ولكن تم تأجيله
في يوم ربيعي جميل بدأ الناس في
القدوم إليه.  حوالي الساعة
العاشرة ، يشتبه في أن أحد المخبرين أخبر
الروس متى يجب أن يضربوا الحد الأقصى من
الخسائر في صفوف المدنيين ،
أعتقد أن هناك شخصًا ما مخربًا
أو شخصًا اختار بالضبط
الوقت المناسب عندما كان معظم الناس
بالخارج وكان هناك حشد بالفعل
يتجمع  ربما أعطيت
الأمر بإطلاق الصاروخ
لرؤية كل هؤلاء الجرحى على مدار
الشهر ونصف الشهر الماضي ،
لقد كان مدمرًا كنت تشاهد هذا
الآن
منذ شهر ونصف.
ما كان رد فعلك العاطفي
للحرب الأهلية كان لدي 50  - محادثة دقيقة مع
طبيب نفساني وكانت هذه هي المرة الأولى التي
شعرت فيها ببعض الراحة
ولكنها لم تنته
من مقعد الصف الأمامي لما يفعله الروس
مما
شاهدته ورأيته  أستطيع أن أقول إنني أدرك أنها ليست حربًا ، إنه
إرهاب محض ،
كل شيء ليس هادئًا على الجبهة الشرقية
لأوكرانيا ليس بعيدًا عن بلدة باروينكوفيك
الروسية الهاون يحذرون مما سيأتي
ويقول المسؤولون الأوكرانيون إن الهجوم في
منطقة دونباس في الجزء الشرقي من
أوكرانيا
ربما بدأ  لديه
أو ربما كان هذا هو التخفيف
قبل الهجوم
بين القوات الأوكرانية ، نحن
أقوى من
هذا الضابط الذي يعطي تقييمًا أكثر واقعية
بأن الروس يبنون
لهجوم قادمون
وقادم ويخبرني الملازم ليونيد أننا '  ليس
في موقف سهل ،
أدى القصف الروسي يوم الثلاثاء إلى مقتل ثلاثة
أشخاص من بينهم فتاة تبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا
وفقًا لرئيس بلدية المدينة
الذي كان يحث السكان على المغادرة
لا يستجيب الجميع
لدعوته ، والقلة العنيدة تنتظر الإمدادات ،
فهذه مدينتنا تصر غالينا نحن
بالبقاء هنا نعلم أن جنودنا
يحموننا. يبدو أن يودميلا تتطلع إلى قوة أعلى
سنصلي إلى الله وتقول إنه ربما
سينقذنا جميعًا
[موسيقى]
ييليس أفيتا البالغة من العمر 83 عامًا تجلس خارج
منزلها ، وهي أيضًا ستبقى
، لكن زوجة ابني خائفة ومن
المحتمل أن تغادر اليوم كما تقول ، لكنني
لست خائفة
، ثم تنطلق في
عاصفة تجمع دراجتها.